right from the air to the ground we have
a viewer email about single occupant
cars in the hov lane in this case terry
is concerned about access to the south
95
from elkhorn check it out terry writes
hey i thought the hov on ramps reserved
for cars with more than one occupant
most of the vehicles getting on the
freeway there only have one occupant
once they're on they quickly move over
to the regular travel lanes
terry continues it'd be easier for me to
get on the 95 in elkhorn but i'm usually
by myself
don't want to get a ticket seeing all
those single occupant vehicles getting
on the freeways driving me
crazy and terry continues it makes me
feel like i'm wasting my time driving up
to durango just to get on the south 95
what gives
while ndot's tony ilya writes back the
driver is correct that the hov on ramp
from elkhorn to the south 95
is reserved for vehicles with two or
more folks but that does also include
buses car pools and van pools as well as
motorcycles
and first responders but tony continues
he's encouraging the viewer to take
advantage of the hop lanes and he puts
in a plug for the regional
transportation commission's
club ride program that's where drivers
who are going the same place at the same
time
can get connected terry i hope this
helps thanks to you
and tony for writing in from ndot buckle
up drive carefully please put down that
phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com